it's not very many people really know
but the Great Lakes has thousands of
shipwrecks in Wisconsin for sure we know
we have 750 historic shipwreck losses my
name is Kaitlin Zant and I'm a maritime
archaeologist with the Wisconsin
Historical Society I would say the main
goal of what we do in maritime
archaeology is to preserve our maritime
history and also the history of the
United States in general the ships are
quite sturdy but they've also been
underwater for up to 100 150 years our
shipwrecks don't disappear over time
like they do in the oceans the
freshwater that's very cold actually
does a really good job at preserving
these shipwrecks one of the really great
things about Lake Michigan that makes it
really unique is the fact that you do
have fresh clear water you can see many
times especially on deep wrecks 100 to
150 feet when you were down there
looking at a shipwreck you start to
think of all the sailors that sailed on
it or if it was a passenger ship the
passengers that happen to be on it you
can still find pieces of clothing in
certain areas buttons shoes and so that
really gives insight to the lives of
these sailors there's definitely a
little bit of a thrill of discovery when
we go down on a ship even on a ship that
we know we think we know what it is
there's still always that little sense
of excitement that you're going to find
something that no one else has seen
before